foreign
pieces of research out there
that uh talk about that that married
people people who are married versus
single or versus uh shacking up
uh have a financial advantage and and
the researchers have always called it
the marriage Advantage
um that that they tend to build more
wealth than any other category
um and
um also tend to move uh uh as a category
not not it's a generalization but I mean
in other words there's exceptions within
each category but they also tend to move
faster in their incomes and their
careers
uh and uh researchers have long tried to
figure out what is causing that exactly
but they call it the marriage advantage
that it's to your advantage
statistically uh as far as wealth goes
income and wealth in general to be
married uh Wall Street Journal comes out
today with yet another study moving in
together doesn't match the financial
benefits of marriage but why a walk down
the aisle can be a route to greater
wealth and prosperity for couples in the
U.S married people have higher net
worths and are more likely to be
homeowners than their unmarried
counterparts their age as of 2019 the
median net worth for cohabitating
checking up couples age 25 to 34 was 17
000 a quarter of that of 68 000 married
couples of exactly the same age range so
25 the net worth of a married couple on
average according to data from the
Federal Reserve Bank of St Louis for
singles at 7 only three hundred dollars
over the past two decades Americans are
moving in together at higher rates and
the share of U.S adults who are
currently married steadily declined from
close to 60 percent in the 90s to half
uh to under half in 2019 according to
Pew who did the research over the same
period the share of adults 18 to 44
living with a partner climbed to 59
percent many young couples now approach
marriage as a Capstone event uh the
sociology professor says that John if
you build an ark the Cornerstone
uh while there are legal and tax
advantages to marriage research suggests
the financial security and long-term
mindset of those who tie the knot may
also be a powerful driver of wealth more
married couples pool their money such as
sharing savings accounts and investing
together to achieve certain goals
cohabitating couples are less likely to
combine finances and Investments working
with two incomes and combining their
Investments to maximize compound
interest can significantly increase a
couple's Financial prospects the
research shows simply put married people
may be more likely to be on the same
page financially and housing is one of
the biggest factors in establishing a
couple's wealth compared with single
people and cohabitating Couples married
couples hold a larger concentration of
housing wealth they're more likely to
own a home if you're married than you
are if you're with a roommate
socioeconomic factors play a role in the
difference between married and partner
wealth the higher your income the
likelier it is you'll marry
well that would affect these numbers and
you know that'd be a cause and effect
issue right there you know which one's
causation and which one's correlation at
that point but
yeah but that yet this is fresh data and
showing the advantages of marriage and I
think the couple that just did the
debt-free scream they're a perfect
example of this data and how it can be
effective I mean in their story they're
talking about how they got on the same
page they set goals they set a why and
they really learn to work together I
think a lot of people who are just
cohabitating they're not having those
conversations they're not getting into
you know shared goals and a shared
mindset of really attacking their
finances well what we do know and this
is fairly easy to extrapolate into this
conversation with with reasonable
certainty
um is that
there is a there is a direct correlation
between the length of your planning
window
how far out in the future you look with
money and how much money you have if you
think thank God it's Friday oh God it's
Monday and you live for the weekend
you're Huey Lewis and the News right uh
then you're gonna be broke your whole
life YOLO right you know that's where
you're going to be you're not gonna have
any money because you don't plan past
Friday night you're just trying to drink
your face off on the weekend and forget
it and you're not planning but when we
when we interview wealthy people the
wealthier they are the longer their
planning window has been for many years
and that's what caused them to be
wealthy in other words when they get
ready to buy a car they don't think
about
this weekend they don't think about this
year they think about five years from
now how's this car purchase going to
affect me they have and when you think
longer term you automatically will
invest more because you're thinking long
term you're believing there is a future
and I'm I and I'm I know my future self
needs to like my current self but future
self doesn't talk to
um
a present self with the the broker
somebody is and the more likely they are
to be broke so if you want to go from
broke to wealthy the point is change
your planning window mindset quit living
for the weekend and start thinking okay
in 50 years where do I want to be
I want to change my family tree how
about in 150 years
what do I want my great grandkids to be
let's look at compound interest at 150
years and play with some numbers that
will blow your freaking mind by the way
uh how many hundreds of millions of
dollars that can become you can be old
man Rockefeller old man Vanderbilt uh
old lady Vanderbilt whatever get this
thing started so that planning window
thing comes in there so that comes into
then this discussion of marriage
as if you're married
unless you are planning to divorce right
now you are thinking you're going to do
Life 50 years from now with this person
right yeah and when you're cohabitating
you're thinking well maybe
that's the chance it's not exactly sure
and it changes your shortens your
planning window when you're shocked
instead of married and so that's one of
the things that I've always thought it
gives you the marriage Advantage because
very few cohabitating couples think
what's gonna what's gonna what's life
gonna be like in 40 years
right well I think it's interesting this
article says that a lot of people see it
as a as a Cornerstone event so what this
means is that people see an economic bar
they need to clear before they get
married couples wait until they have
good jobs a car that won't break down
maybe even a house then they get married
which I think is interesting because
it's like they're trying to do something
in in order to get themselves it'd be a
lot easier right they're married but
they're actually holding themselves back
yeah that's that's interesting that the
data shows that yep so if you're in that
boat and you're feeling you know
hesitant to get married because you feel
like you have to meet a certain
barometer you need to have a certain
amount of your debt paid off you feel
like you need to have a better job or a
house that actually could be working
against you if you actually find the
right partner if you find someone that
you know you want to be with for the
rest of your life getting married
actually could set you on way better
footing financially and it it is not
smart to combine your accounts with
somebody you're not married to totally
and there is uh all kinds of data
including this data here that says
combined accounts I have a tendency
towards more wealth again it's a unified
look at the future it's a fairly simple
concept if you're not thinking about the
future you're not going to have one
right you know if you're not intentional
about future you're not going to have
one and you know I don't care if you're
26 or you're 36 you're shacking up you
aren't that you're not talking about
changing my family tree that doesn't
come up
otherwise you would have already gone
done
if you want to change your family tree
you need to have a family to change the
tree I mean you know there's not there's
not even a tree not even a family so I
mean you're you're not thinking that way
you the inherent in the socioeconomic
and the psychology of living together
versus marriage is short-term thinking
versus long-term thinking and that will
always limit your wealth so you know
these guys that call us up here and they
go well you know we've been engaged for
10 years and I'm like dude painter get
off the ladder really and they do call
us and tell us that and I've had and
I've had a few calls over the years that
they've been separated but not divorced
for seven years and I'm like why well I
don't want to I don't want to get
divorced well you are divorced you just
hadn't admitted it yet oh my gosh that
is not a good long-term strategy
you have where there is no vision that
people perish
if you think long term and you think
long term with your partner called
marriage you have a much higher
statistical probability of Building
Wealth and therefore if you don't do
that on purpose then you have no right
to whine about having not built wealth
it's not anybody's fault but yours
ding ding the marriage advantage